queen elizabeth is facing yet another
loss
her majesty's five-month-old puppy
fergus has reportedly died
the puppy is said to have been gifted to
the queen earlier this year when her
late husband prince philip was in the
hospital
according to multiple reports fergus was
thought to have been a dorky
a corgi dachshund mix he was named after
the queen's late
uncle who died during world war one in
1915.
this is not the first time the 95 year
old rainey monarch has lost a fur baby
back in december royal correspondents
also reported her loyal companion vulcan
who was also a dorky died just weeks
before christmas
in may 2016 queen elizabeth posed for
the cover of vanity fair with vulcan and
her other doggies
candy holly and willow in honor of her
90th birthday
the queen loves corgis so she's had
corgis her whole life
and they are very much associated with
the british family clearly her fur
babies have been extremely important to
her ever since she was giving her first
corgi dookie when she was seven years
old it's been a tough year for the queen
just last month she lost her 99 year old
husband
prince phillip
[Music]
and she recently just celebrated her
95th birthday without him
her first birthday without her beloved
by her side in over seven decades
royal expert katie nichol told et at the
time how her majesty was feeling ahead
of the milestone
well it is indeed a very somber birthday
for the queen of course the first
birthday that she will have spent
in 73 years without the duke of
edinburgh by her side
so a lonely birthday but she has not
been
completely on her own we understand that
she has been visited by
some family members today the queen has
two birthdays
she has her actual birthday which is
today the 21st of april
and then she has her official birthday
celebrations
in june which everyone will recognize as
trooping the color
so the birthday in april is always a
pretty low-key affair
so today is always a relatively quiet
day a low-key day but of course today is
all the harder for not having philip by
her side